valerian's third episode released today
and it could change the meta more than
any other in the game's history there's
just one
problem pro players have been practicing
on a
very different patch and even with the
new agent disabled for the qualifiers
that start
in less than a week it's going to be a
mad scramble to figure out
who's going to come out on top if you're
a pro
player that craves chaos episode 3
might be exactly what you were waiting
for
killer robots from the future are pretty
scary but
you know what is it liking the video
hitting the subscribe button and ringing
the notification bell maybe it will help
prevent the future where killer robots
are developed but
no promises on that one so valorance
episode 3
act 1 is live on servers now one of the
biggest changes it
brings is the introduction of the new
agent
a killer robot named ko this character
is classified as an initiator but
really the important point is this two
of ko's ability to press opponents so
that they
can't activate their own abilities
here's sentinel sick
demonstrating the radius of the zero
point ability
shutting them down holy [ __ ] that's
massive
so this suppresses people so that means
so that means people can't use abilities
basically so opponents who are fast
enough
can destroy the knife before the
suppression happens but
as you can see it goes off pretty quick
and ko knows which enemy asians are
affected by the ability so
you could use it for intel as well does
this do damage
that's not on top of suppression
the agent's flashbang seems to be pretty
handy on
nearly any team composition his
flashbang
that is really good so it bounces off
people right yeah it does
oh that's a standard flash i feel like
that's gonna be what he's used for most
just be like oh you wanna do you wanna
[ __ ] peak all right cool
this could have huge implications for
the competitive meta we saw in iceland
the so-called post-plant meta which
emphasizes planting the bomb
and then preventing the defuse through
the use of utility like viper snake
bites
astra stars or killjoy grenades now we
have an agent that can
do something about the ability-focused
post-plant strategy that we've seen so
often recently
and that could shake up a lot about how
pro players approach the game
on top of that with this latest patch
agent abilities have been rebalanced
nearly across the board that
includes a change to ability costs where
for the first time in the game's young
history
some of them end in 50 instead of all
being multiples of a hundred and the
kind of ability that was used to help
popularize a post-plant meta has been
pretty drastically nerfed in many cases
viper snake bite costs double you only
get one free astra star
stuff like that critically important
agents like sova
aren't going to disappear but with these
increased costs
that potential intel that you picked
them for just got a lot more expensive
i'm wondering whether reyes will be as
popular as she used to be with
her all costing a whole extra charge and
on top of that boombot costing double
means that it's a lot more difficult
to blindly roll that thing into garage
i'm willing to bet that won't stop
your team's race from doing it though
and that's probably right before they
blast pack onto sight get destroyed in a
crossfire
and then blame you for not refragging
sorry i've
had some bad games anyways if you're a
jet mane
maybe think about picking up phoenix
basically everything about jet was
nerfed
increased ability costs alt is harder to
charge
and you can't even charge through
tripwires anymore and with jet now
unable to just burst onto a site
tripwires be damned
those executes that started the quick
takes of the post plant meta
could be a thing of the past so maybe
you're a jet man looking for a new pick
well as valor caster a evil cat pointed
out
it's possible that former duelist
players could pick up
ko given that he can still flash himself
into a sight
plus he brings that suppression utility
now on to the weapon cost changes
like i said this is a pretty thick
update these changes had been leaked
for a while but with the patch now going
live
we could see an increased focus on the
op
cheekier partial buys and maybe even
more than the occasional
guardian sighting yes in someone's hands
other than hikos in particular the
cheaper 4700 credit op
combined with those jet nerfs we talked
about
could mean a bit of a shake-up earlier
this month
after those weapon changes were leaked
but before the ability changes we just
talked about were revealed
we asked asuna about both the op and jet
the reason why you up on jet is like
because of the mobility stuff but also
the abilities like they're really cheap
so
it works out nicely where you don't need
to buy abilities for certain like rounds
you already have your like
dash and then like all the other stuff
is like not even necessary to a certain
extent
again to be clear that clip was from
before
the ability nerfs were revealed so now
we have to ask
is there another operator that fits that
description
and that might be able to buy some
significant utility in
overtime rounds for example is the era
of jet ops supremacy over
or will jet offers just have to do more
with less and sure the op is cheaper now
but
the increasing cost to jet's abilities
easily cancels that out if you're
throwing smokes or using
updraft regularly and speaking of weapon
changes nearly every weapon in the game
has had its accuracy while moving
substantially reduced
particularly walking accuracy pros don't
typically make a habit of firing on the
move constantly but
this is another change that will simply
have to be figured out okay so we've
talked a lot about the
meta but how is this going to affect
professional play
well this patch has landed less than a
week before the first open
qualifier for eu's stage 3 challengers
1 tournament on june 28th thankfully ko
is disabled at that qualifier
as well as the first qualifier in na
but with so little time before these
tournaments teams will still be
scrambling to try to
figure everything out so whatever we do
see next week will be kind of a
strange in-between meta but
maybe we'll be able to see if the
ability changes
on their own have done substantial work
to address the post plant meta professor
of tea bagging
and masters 2 champion dapper said that
the meta changes could be
even bigger than ko but until we
actually see the agent in pro hands
we won't get that answer there's another
big change happening at the same time
too brees will be available for
competitive play
at this event it had been slated to
debut at reykjavik
for masters too but players complain
that there wasn't much time to learn the
map
and so its introduction to competitive
was postponed
until now when a lot of other changes
are just
hitting the game so here's the last
thing about this patch dimension
considering all the changes we just
talked about
and the amount of time that these
changes will be in effect before
qualifiers spin up
pro players have been grinding practice
on a patch for weeks
that's simply no longer relevant that
can be
a frustrating thing to realize as
hundred thieves as ethan
pointed out on twitter being handed this
weird rubik's cube of a meta right
before competition resumes is pretty
difficult
it emphasizes adaptation over
iteration while some teams thrive on
figuring things out in the moment
other teams are built more for
perfecting established metas
and truthfully in nearly every esport
the teams revered as great didn't just
figure out the patch in its early days
they managed to stay great for a
significant amount of time but if you're
an
avid fan that wants to see a big
shake-up of the valorant meta
you're probably going to get your wish
especially once we see pros in action
with ko are you guys going to be
checking out any of the qualifiers on
the way to masters 3 in berlin
and do you think ko is the answer that
the game needs
to disrupt the post plant meta let me
know
in the comments below so somebody told
me
like a long time ago somebody's like
this guy sounds like the burger king
foot lettuce guy
burger king foot lettuce the last thing
you want to find
in your burger king burger is someone's
foot fungus
but it turns out that might be exactly
what you get
if this makes it in the video let me
know in the comments if i sound like the
burger king foot lettuce guy